foreign
over the past two years how many times
have you heard that the times have
changed or about The New Normal
there's no shortage of opinions about
whether remote work is for the better or
spells Destruction for our businesses
Reid Hasting CEO of Netflix said I don't
see any positives whereas Suresh Kumar
CTO of Walmart said we haven't just
coped we've actually thrived
but what does the research say how can
we know not just think
that hybrid working actually works
there's so many questions what's the
right balance of work from home versus
work from the office and who gets to
decide is it managers is it the
employees is it both
how long can a given employee actually
remain productive working from home is
there a limit
and who gets to work in each way what it
should be based on in terms of criteria
should it be based on seniority task
personal situation the list goes on and
on so many questions and unfortunately
no simple answers
the reason these questions are so hard
to answer is because we're thinking
about hybrid work design as a single
problem
one problem to solve when in fact it's
actually three different ones the first
problem is are we able to effectively
deliver on our stakeholder commitments
this is otherwise known as the
effectiveness debate
the second is will we be able to attract
and retain the talent that we need
this is the Staffing discussion
and the third is can we maintain or even
cultivate nurture our culture this is
the talk about social fabric
let's take a minute to highlight the
challenges inherent in each one
I've been working with a range of
organizations over the past two years
helping them determine what their future
of work should look like now I'm not
here to make a broad statement that
remote work is or is not universally
good I think we're all smart enough here
to know that nothing works all of the
time
I am however here to warn you that we
need to be wary of our data let me give
you a couple of examples many people
point to their organization's
Effectiveness during covid as proof that
they're actually good at remote work now
it is proof that remote can work but not
that it necessarily will
was a massive social experiment with
unique conditions most organizations
dealt with it by cutting the fat and
becoming laser focused on short-term
efficiency
in effect we were productive because we
were in survival mode
but the question we have to ask is
whether that's sustainable
data shows around the world that
people's working hours have increased
and many say that they actually find it
harder to delineate work life boundaries
data also shows that the experience
wasn't the same for everyone with the
economist data showing that parents of
school-aged children experienced much
greater stress than many others
and data for Microsoft shows that it's
actually even changing the way in which
we work with people working more hours
but less collaboratively
the question of whether we can
effectively work remotely needs a
contextual answer contextual based on
the people who are doing the work and
the tasks that they're trying to
accomplish remember one size fits none
and we need to think about the
sustainability of our Effectiveness now
when it comes to the Staffing discussion
ask anyone who has recently been
involved with hiring the most common
question that recruiters are being asked
these days what is your flexible work
policy
in effect we're facing the same
escalation of perks popularized by tech
companies during the boom do you have a
barista pulling the perfect flat white
in the lobby do you have nap pods a ball
pit a slide what about on-site daycare
right so instead of work from home we
actually bring home into work your
current or potential future employees
are now weighing your hybrid work policy
as a key criteria in their decision of
where they want to work and that is the
Crux of this Staffing challenge what you
need to recognize is that the comparison
isn't actually between work from home
and office work
instead it's really between the
perception of work from home versus the
perception of work from the office and
you need to reclaim that narrative
let me give you a couple of examples the
first is what I call the recovered
commute many people have told me I've
saved so much time now that I don't have
to commute
my challenge to them what did you
actually do during your commute times
maybe you read maybe you caught up on
calls or emails maybe you just use it as
time to decompress personally I used to
get an hour to shake off a particularly
rough annoying frustrating day
before I got home now it takes me
exactly six seconds to be immersed in my
family upstairs
another example the after meeting
post-mortem debrief over a coffee right
we use that to do some relationship
repair maybe to do some collective sense
making
the most important thing to recognize
here is that what matters most is the
experience not just what the policy is
we need to reclaim the narrative to help
ensure that everybody recognizes what a
given approach either buys or loses for
them
and this brings us to the social fabric
think about what happened when you
joined your organization you probably
went to orientation maybe you you looked
around you talked to some people you
observed and you learned what it's like
to work here why does that matter well
because our research shows reductions in
things like psychological safety and
Trust changes to power dynamics
increased feelings of isolation and
loneliness when we are working remote
from one another
importantly all of these shape our
cultures and make this conversation even
more difficult and on top of that social
systems are Dynamic emerging evolving
human systems now I'm going to be honest
I don't have the answer to this and
honestly anybody who tells you they do
they're trying to sell you something
we do know about different approaches to
building and establishing culture in
these contexts what we have to recognize
is they operate in ways that may not be
the same as the way we build culture
when we were face to face
what we have to remember here is that
organizational culture is a long game
what we do right now affects the social
fabric of our organizations and will
have repercussions down the line
so when it comes to the social fabric we
need to think not only about today but
about tomorrow next month maybe even
next year
I hope you recognize that these are
three distinct conversations that are
also not fully independent we also have
to recognize what makes this challenging
is that they are almost ideologically
different positions about what creates
value in your organization is it about
the output of what you produce is it
about the people in that organization or
something in The Ether the culture
the first most important step is getting
these issues on the table having an open
conversation and this is far from Easy
but if you find yourself in disagreement
with somebody over these issues whether
it's a boss a subordinate or your
leadership
I challenge you ask yourself do you
really disagree on how to create
Effectiveness deal with Staffing or the
culture of the organization or is it
maybe just that you have slightly
different prioritizations of those three
different parts of the whole hybridity
conversation